good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to this press event on the first
issuance of bombs in the context of
next generation eu we will start
with a statement by the president of the
european commission mrs
fonda lyon after which we will continue
with a press conference
by commissioner han on the issuance of
the bombs
president you have the floor thank you
very much and
good evening so today we reached a key
milestone
in the implementation of our recovery
plan next generation eu
next generation eu will provide in
today's prices
800 billion euros
to reshape our continent for decades
ahead
to build a more sustainable a more
digital and of course a more resilient
euro
to fund next generation eu we have
agreed
that the commission will raise the
necessary capital
on the market and today we have
successfully conducted
the first issuance operation for next
generation eu
the commission has just raised 20
billion euros
in the capital markets by issuing a
10-year bond
this is the largest ever institutional
bond issuance
in europe and i'm very pleased that this
attracted
very strong interest by a wide range of
investors
the bond was over subscribed seven
times and the bond was priced under very
attractive terms we are paying less than
0.1 interest on it
today's deal confirms that europe is
attractive by the end of this year
we expect to have issued around 100
billion
in bonds and bills this will enable us
to fund
all planned grants and loans for member
states this year
and this shows that next generation eu
is a huge
opportunity for us we need to invest
this money well
to make the best out of it now how are
we going to proceed
after very intense dialogue with
national governments
we have completed our commission's
assessments
of several national recovery and
resilience plans
and from tomorrow on i will travel to
these member states
so this week i will visit portugal spain
greece denmark and luxembourg
and i'm planning more trips in the
following weeks
i want at this point to thank everyone
for the incredible work done
to produce these ambitious plans
but we all know it's good to have a plan
but this is only the start now we have
to
implement them we have to launch the
transformation of our economies
and we have to make sure that the plans
are in line with european priorities
we know that on paper they are now we
have to make sure that the
implementation of these ambitious goals
takes place
and we will be very vigilant to make
sure that this implementation is
rigorous
we want the best value for our economies
but we want
also the best value for our citizens and
i'm very glad to see
how next generation eu is now becoming a
reality
before i end i really want to thank
commissioner han
diegio for the outstanding work
you've done and the big success of today
so you can be
really proud of it and it's a great
achievement so
good luck on your press conference and
thanks
thank you very much dear president thank
you for this
very kind final words but uh it would
only be
possible and it was only possible to
achieve this
by having an excellent team there's our
general director georgian copman
my team in the cabinet but in particular
the team around
niall pohan with his uh
people i was there yesterday in
luxembourg
they have not only issued today's
first next generation newborns but
already
the sure issuance was a part of their
and is their
work and their success but uh
i think indeed today we can be
proud and happy about this first
ngo issuance however i would not
interpret it as a
hamiltonian moment as some of you might
call it
i want to be a little bit more modest
concrete and self-confident but rather
saying it's a
truly european uh moment as it
demonstrates the union's
innovation and transformative power but
to understand the significance of this
uh first transaction
let the stake briefly look back
slightly more than 12 months ago the
european commission put forward the
ambitious
proposal for a reinforced mff
for a long term budget but also for the
next generation
eu instrument almost
11 months ago eu leaders approved it
and during the second largest
second longest year european council
meeting you remember almost 100 hours
and in december our final package was
officially endorsed
also by the european parliament and
finally member states
ratified their own resources decision in
a record time
of just five months i'm saying this
because
the previous exercise on this took 28
months so here
this five months is definitely record
time
with the early launch of next generation
eu we are able to provide member states
citizens and regions with that much
needed money the president
was already referring to her travels and
to reach out to member states to convey
this positive future into the
message and now it's time really to
invest
in future rented projects pursuing our
political priorities clean deal
digitalization
and so the the recovery and resilience
plan can now be indeed implemented and
the financial means provided
in addition our transaction will provide
the necessary funds to reinforce
innovative programs within the core
mff like the health program the actions
dedicated to fight climate change
research and development program in
those boosting
digitalization so the ngo money is not
only there
to repair but also to transform
the president already referred to the
key figures it was
20 billion euro today
far more than we have originally
aimed at but it was 10 years maturity
but it was due to the fact that the
order poop was 142
and we really wanted to serve our
loyal and motivated investors as much as
possible and that's why
finally we ended up with this huge
amount a huge amount which is
finally the largest ever issuance
from a european public sector
institution national
or european it's the largest ever
syndicated
single branch transaction and the
largest amount the union
has raised in a single transaction
it was therefore it's easy to calculate
more than seven times over subscribed
and i have to say this in an
environment which is less
attractive than it was autumn last year
when we issued
the first sure bonds so nevertheless we
could
attract so many and reach out to so many
investors and all this allowed us to
price the bond at
very attractive terms as it was said
we are paying less than 0.1 in
percentage interest but i think this
again
is an expression of the extra
attractiveness of this very successful
transaction now what's
ahead of us not talking about what the
president
has already referred but simply saying
this is
just the beginning you know we have to
raise over the years
up to in current prices 800
billions the
commission will still carry out two more
significant
syndicated transaction under next
generation u
in the weeks before end of july one
most likely still in june the other one
in july
in september we will start our eu bill
and bond auction program this will give
us additional flexibility
in raising ngo funds on the most
advantageous
terms and there and we also will review
our funding plan in september to take
stock of the latest informations
on the disbursement schedule to member
states because as you know we had the
finalization
of the reform plans and then we have a
better understanding
what are sort of the financial needs and
also in terms of the timetable that's
why we need to revise our funding plan
which usually is
developed always for one semester
and we will also come for the first time
with green bonds in autumn
after the ngo greenbone framework
is set up and the green pond issuance
will demonstrate
our financial transactions and political
priorities
interlinked and uh i have to say once
all the green bonds and it should be
around 30 percent which is probably
around 270 280 billions in
current prices this would double
the current global greenpoint market
like the sure ponds
have tripled the social pond the global
social bond
market by the end of 2021
we expect to raise at least some 80
billion
in bonds to be complimented if necessary
and it will be the case by short-term eu
bills
and this will allow us to show the
necessary flexibility
to serve the financial needs and
expectations
of our member states a few words about
the political and economic significance
of this exercise apart from its
substantial
contribution to the union's recovery the
ngo
issuances will establish the union as a
key player on the debt
capital markets issuing liquid highly
rated debt of
interest to both domestic and
international
investors in this way our issuances
will also strengthen the international
role of the euro
the start of our eu bill issuance
program
with three and six month papers will be
another
major milestone in terms of building the
union issuance as a strong reference
for international investors looking for
euro denominated
exposure and safe european assets
the good result finally of today's deal
is a vote of confidence
in the union as an issuer and in the
union's capacity to deliver
even an unprecedented crisis such as
the current pandemic for the sake of our
citizens thank you commissioner for your
words for your introduction on this
important day
and now it's time to take a few
questions so if you have any please
raise your hand i will wait a couple of
seconds
paula why don't you take the floor
thank you do you hear me commissioner
yes
thank you um do you have a breakdown by
type
and geographically of the investors
from this first issuance
yeah so far more than 50 percent
of the of the uh
issuance went to the union
we have outside europe outside europe
around 13 in asia and the americas
and if it's about the character or the
kind of
investors we have central banks with
around
a quarter fund managers 37 percent
pension funds and insurance funds around
11 percent
uh in general one can say we managed
really to
interest and attract long-term investors
which is
clearly has been clearly our goal and
i'm happy about this structure
of investors thank you and now the floor
goes to
rafaela
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
please
yes thanks for the floor uh uh fonder
lion said that she will visit five
countries
this week as we all know but there are
rumors about uh
um a visit by van der lyon next week
next tuesday
in rome and some media i have already
written this news if you can confirm it
please thanks
i think she has mentioned some countries
but i have to admit i'm not
sort of say aware about her
travel calendar but certainly the most
important countries
concerning the implementation
of the reform plan definitely
i think on top of her travel agenda
thank you and now i give the floor to
daniel weber
[Music]
[Music]
thank you i will now bring in rita cesar
apologies for not having my camera
i just wanted to clarify if the
college of commissioners today signed
off on the uh
and resilience plans that the
president president of the commission
has just mentioned if they were
formally approved today and the
recommendation
for uh approval by the council
has already been signed off thank you
i left the college at 5 30 but at that
time it was already aob
and we didn't approve anything today
thank you and now i give the floor to
david carrata
thank you very much apologize i have
some connection problem today
so i cannot switch on my camera david
carreta
can you confirm that 10 banks that has
breached antitrust rules um
um will not be involved
in the financing of the
next generation eu and
if yes why thank you well
they have been well known in the
meantime well-known cartel cases
and there is a decision
uh by the the commission
uh to find them for their
uh collusions which they took place in
the past
uh part of this decision were
where also the demand to
apply certain remedial measures
these banks or many of them have
qualified themselves
for the primary dealer network but we
took the decision
for the time being as long as they have
not yet
provided us with necessary additional
information
that therefore the time being excluded
from sovereign
issuances thank you
and now i give the four to tomas
migliarina
and thank you commissioner apologies if
this is a little technical in fact it's
a follow-up of
paula tamma's question do you know um
can you tell us
um you have data about how much
switzerland has been interested in
in buying uh next generation u swiss
swiss investors i'm from swiss
television as you might imagine thank
you
i don't have final figures but
switzerland participated
demonstrating its commitment to the
european union
all right thank you
very much please go ahead
yes hello thank you for the question i'm
with the german press agency my name is
marina schmidt rochman
um i was wondering if you could uh
explain
a little bit why germany who which was
among the first states to um to come up
with uh
an rrf plan is not among the first to be
awarded
or to to to pass the um your exam
examination thank you honestly i have to
admit i'm not directly
involved in this assessment process
but i understand that germany have
submitted like many others
a very well-drafted
fine-tuned program and of course it
takes its time to discuss it but i
cannot
confirm in one or the other way how fast
the approval will take place but i think
one can be confident that this will
be the case very soon thank you
tomasze galawati
good afternoon commissioner thank you
for the floor it's just a question about
the demand uh did you have a
huge demand from chinese investors and
do you
do you foresee a demand from that area
of the world
thank you for these bonds this time
we had around 10 percent from asia
i have no further breakdowns but
i'm sure that china will be a
significant
share of it
thank you and give the floor to martha
carrasco please
for the floor i'm sorry i have to insist
in a question of one of my colleagues
because i didn't really understand the
answer
a president from the lawyer mentioned
different countries which is going to
travel the next days
and i'm not really sure if the plans of
this country the spanish
spanish planning concrete is already
approved
or you have finished the assessment and
this plan is going to be approved
tomorrow by
written procedure or what is it thank
you very much
commission internally we will certainly
take the necessary decisions
of course allowing the president to
submit
the positive messages but then of course
it has also to be
approved by the council you i will take
one
final question colleagues because we
need to proceed with the readout
and that will go to anna hirtenstein
hi i think you're taking my question
i've got another question
on the banks that have been excluded
from the issuances
what exactly do these banks have to do
to for this no longer to be the case and
how long do you think this might take
well these banks have to
these banks have to demonstrate and to
prove
that they have taken
all the necessary remedial actions
which have been demanded by the
commission when
deciding about these cases
and this is something which where we now
expect
the submission of the necessary
informations and then of course
we have to analyze it and assess it and
i cannot predict how long it takes it
depends on the quality of material
and information provided to us
what we will do as fast as possible
because we have
our interest to include uh all the key
players and banks which have qualified
themselves
for the primary dealer network but of
course
the the so today uh the
the legal aspects have to be respected
thank you commissioner han with that for
briefing us on this very uh exceptional
day and thank you for coming
and posing your questions to us please
don't forget that now we'll proceed with
the readout in the press room
have a good afternoon
[Music]
you